welcome back to 820 special relativity
in this section we want to talk about
particles in accelerators and we use
the large electron position collider at
cern as an example
lab the large electron position collider
was a collider which was operated in the
late 1980s up to the year 2000
at center of mass energies from 91 gev
to
up to 209 gev
this energies were used to probe the
z-boson to produce pairs of w boson and
also to look for the higgs boson which
didn't quite work because energy wasn't
quite sufficient
the 27 kilometer or about 16 mile
circumference collider is now the home
of the large utron collider etc and it's
being used there to collide protons with
protons
um lab had four experiments alef delf
delphi l3 and opal and i was happy to
you know study data from the opal
detector as part of my undergraduate
undergraduate thesis so this was very
good memories there
but that's not the topic today so the
topic of the day is to
find out how quickly or fast
the particles in the collider moving
when we know the center of mass energy
so if you know the center of mass energy
to be 209 geb we know that the
energy in the beam is half of that 104.5
gb
um so now to figure out how fast the
electrons are moving the electrons and
the positrons we can use our
relativistic total energy for the
electron or for the proton which is the
kinetic energy plus the rest mass of the
electron or positron which is m naught
gamma times c square
so with a mass of 511 kv over c square
and this
energy of
104.5 gb
this results in a gamma factor of 200
000
and if you do the mass you'll find that
electrons and positrons are almost
moving
with the speed of light in where moving
this is speed of light
um as a in a fun additional fact is we
are working right now on proposing
a even larger collider which will then
allow it to efficiently go up to
energies of 350 geb and that collider
then will be able to
you know study the higgs boson with
precision but also look at top pair
production top crop hair production in
this kind of color
another fun fact is that you know cern
the collider which is about 100 meter
under the surface um is spanning two
countries switzerland and france and so
each particle lapse
lab i mean makes a lab
makes about 11 200 laps per second
that means that there is about 44 800
border crossings for an electron
position so they all constantly have to
show their passport when they're moving
around in that
to look at its second example here
with a small accelerate we can
accelerate electrons through
a electrostatic potential of 511
kilo volts or 0.5 11
mega volts
um the total energy then is again the
kinetic energy plus the rest energy
which is in this example 4.5 11 mev plus
0.511 mev and so here we find the gamma
factor of 2 and a velocity of 0.866
so even in this smaller
electrostatic potential of 500
kilovolts
we find that
electrons are moving with very very high
velocities with velocities very close to
the speed of light
you